l'affaiblissement parce qu ils vont
la technique au pas suivant
quoi qu'ils disent
c'est quoi
et votre humeur
depuis quelque temps nous inquiète marie
fait il se prend pour lui d'être humain
et je n'arrive par l'en dissuader on
sait pas c'est pas que je prenne mon
chien pour trimestre ils baissent et que
les jeux prennent pour quelqu'un c'est
un peu abusif moi j'aimais beaucoup les
bêtes mais j'ai vu j'ai commencé par me
faire mordre par un chien très très très
sévèrement parce qu'ils étaient attachés
au bout d'une chaîne dans une cour de
ferme et je me suis approché pour le
caresser le jem a mordu alors évidemment
ch
là encore je suis resté avec une
mauvaise impression pourquoi pourquoi
j'allais vous le caresser l'enfant peut
pas faire la part des choses du tout
enfin là alors moi je suis resté avec
des choses comme ça si bien que les
animaux jusqu'à un certain âge j'ai un
peut configurer sa effectivement comme
des leaders des êtres à part
quoique
quoique il ya des animaux qu'ils vous
aiment pas et je trouve que c'est très
déplaisant de sentir qu un animal ne
vous convient pas que vous ne lui
convenait pas c'est un est très
inquiétant
évidemment un chien bon moi ça m'a
toujours troublé profondément de ne pas
plaire un animal s'est pas bousculé que
c'est pas bon c'est un chat paillon
déplaire un chat c'est pas bon signe
c'est peut-être ça ne veut pas être pas
dit grand chose je veux dire c'est
peut-être question d'onde
peut-être mais quand même quand je quand
j'appelle un animal comme sacha qui ne
vient pas vers moi c'est comme une
offense
à voir la famille
tyga ça c'est mon copain ça
le matin il vient me réveiller viens me
réveillais voire quelquefois évidemment
et pas envie de me lever à l'heure il
est contrarié les contrarie bout d'1 un
maquis terroristes
oui là un précieux guide aussi comme
quoi un social 1
j'ai l'impression qu'ils disent qu'ici
on était plusieurs il trouverait le
créneau tâche et a créé n'ose aller
regarde un peu la caméra lama qui nuit
les jaloux alors quand ils voient que je
caresse manière générale il coupe il
coupe il vient entre autres makis mois
et qu'à ce cas ces rapports qu'on peut
avoir c'est drôle un lien de parenté
tous les deux nous et l'on est le fils
de maquis figuratif message est sûr
qu'ils ne savent pas annoncer je crois
qui les ignorent totalement freins ils
n'ont pas l'esprit de famille ou alors
ils l'ont trop que les chiens avant ma
qui a eu au tel avec sa soeur j'ai pas
quand même précédent
mais le complexe d'oedipe
oui ce sont des chiens qui sont pas
apprécié du tout vers garder a besoin
besoin enfin j'aurais peut-être fait
dire ça parce que je ne sais pas si si
s'il arrivait quelque chose si l'on
serait mettre si je pouvais les retenir
quand même j'en sais rien mais très
c'est un chien brun oralement ou alors
c'est pour une causerie par futur parce
que moi l'ambré c'est un challenge et
mieux prévoir alors vraiment si c'est
pour lui diront pied si c'est pas donné
des ordres leur nom les chiens les
forces qui vont même leurs huit sages
comprend que héron canton les 13 pour
une raison spéciale pour une fonction
particulière d'accord mais quand même
dressé des animaux moi je n'ose pas trop
parler de ça parce que il est évident
que les gens qui ont dressé un chien en
fond m et ça peut éviter les
catastrophes mais encore une fois ça je
le redis s'il fallait que je retienne
mon chien je sais pas trop comment on y
prendre alors que même quelquefois vient
ici on s'appelait empêcher mais ils nous
aiment tellement bien que quand même ils
désobéissent moi je peux dire que si mes
chiens mobile c'est parce qu'ils
m'aiment bien c'est pas parce que je jeu
les tourments touche les impressionne
n'est pas parce qu'ils ont peur de moi
toi
sûrement pas fait un hommage
puis c'était un chien gars fantastique
maintenant regarder
un peu mais pas garder tout seul c'est
dommage hein
tyga joli petit bonhomme
bon on va avancer sui yamaha tué selon
elle est venue hier magritte et les
guerres
voilà
ce sont même des êtres vivants nous nous
sommes des êtres humains les animaux
sont des êtres vivants et savez la part
le fait de gens ce je vois pas très bien
ce qui peut nous différencier je vois
pas même du tout ils sont censés où ils
souffrent ils ont des visées ils ont d
affection pour tous les sens du terme du
mot il ya quelqu'un intérieur moi j'ai
toujours pensé qu'à l'intérieur d'un
animal y avait quelqu'un je le dis dans
mon chien bon alors mais il ya quand il
ya un maître qui qui s'agitent qui va
qui vient qui respire qui voit puis un
jour humeur ou sinon je ne sais pas si
le sang le pressent aux quoi mais je
veux dire c'est ça qu'il faut respecter
chez les animaux je me promenais avec
mon chien que je tenir en laisse et je
rencontre une avec sa petite fille et
j'entends la dame qui dit à sa petite
fille va sacrifier chien est la
petite-fille vulgariser la main
alors moi qui faisais s'il y avait
erreur sur la personne que le chien
c'était long mais intitulé a continué à
me caresser gentiment la meute et la
dame m'a dit tu vois j'ai pas méchant et
mon chien lui qui ne rate jamais une
occasion de se taire a cru bon d'ajouter
il ne lui manque que la parole avant
j'en ai les gens n'avaient eu un qui
était un chien et non mais enfin il mord
tumeur au cerveau c'était épouvantable
la femme mais cet âge alors un chien
d'une intelligence extraordinaire
extraordinaire il avait repéré comme sa
démo patate
ils savaient ce qu'était une patate
selon lui est pas appris en disant il ya
une d'éducation peut peut-être éduquer
des bêtes comme ça alors montrant
l'objet je sais pas vous ou jamais ce
n'est pas du tout dans notre île à
l'herbe est alors quand on disait pas
attaquer en chercher une est d'amener la
pomme de terre
le reste c'est pas c'est très mystérieux
comme on a du mal à communiquer et vous
regarde et il faut comprendre à travers
leurs regards ce qu'ils veulent alors on
y arrive un peu dans les grandes choses
va pour les buts des choses essentielles
on y arrive mais sans ça c'est un
mystère on ne sait pas ce qui a un jeu
mon chien quand il veut sortir
j'arrive à le savoir parce qu'il tourne
autour de moi et c'est tout juste s'ils
me tire par la manche alors je sens que
mais bon il y en a un qu'il fait mais de
l'autre nous alors on ne sait pas il
voudrait sortie ils peuvent pas le dire
alors il vous regarde ce que ça peut
faire partie de la gym également
beaucoup trop
pour que trouve quand on songe qu'un
chien à moins d'un accident
on le verra mourir il 13 14 ans maximum
alors c'est un compagnon qui vous
accompagnent pendant 13 14 ans mais
quand tout va bien je veux dire et puis
un jour c'est que bon c'est bon ça fait
partie aussi c'est la vie c'est l'ami
ben oui quand m sage je trouve que c c c
'est ce qui ferait on hésite à prendre
un chien chez soi mais c'est dommage
hésité à prendre un compagnon simplement
parce qu'on sait qu'on va le voir mourir
c'est pas une raison suffisante
qu'est ce qui vous a apporté pendant un
certain nombre d'années je crois que
c'est inné green égal à la fidélité
d'une belle amitié
la tendresse pour pas dire l'amour c'est
c'est quand même quelque chose
d'infiniment précieux
je sais j'ai insisté que dernièrement
elle réunion parce que
on vient d'en perdre de perdre le chien
et l'assister donc à une réunion entre
plusieurs personnes comme ça qu'ils
avaient perdu leurs chiens on était
poste quand les mois devient papa vif en
effet presque drôle parce que c'est
trois quatre personnes non j'ai martin
lemire aussi en alors certaines espèces
de la mention effroyable ont tourné sur
alors je me suis surpris à penser que
s'ils avaient eu des témoins il est plus
le train par exemple si une entente à
chiens aboyer maquis va s'insurge alors
côté l'eau s'en va il kriegel un peu et
elle m'a beaucoup de gueule et puis s'en
va et vient avec les êtres humains avec
des êtres dits intelligents espace petit
quelque chose il y avait une espèce de
mutation qui serait on s'en rend
peut-être pas compte mais ce serait
intéressant des films comparaison entre
le l'intelligence si petite soit elle
dans l'animal du 20e siècle avec un
animal de bât du du 14ème 15ème siècle
peut-être qu'il ya une évolution effet
plus intelligent qu'amant peut-être pas
mais il n'est pas impensable de le
dépenser enfin il n'est pas exclu de le
penser c'est assez étonnant que canali
mal tout de même comme ça une certaine
race comme le chat par exemple
petit à petit bascule se met à réfléchir
quelles surprises étonnantes de voir un
chat par exemple celui le premier chat
qui basculerait dans la lave dans la
réflexion qui franchiraient le pas de la
réflexion et qui se trouvera en face de
vous et qui commence à peut-être
articulé certains sons qui vous entendu
10 pour mon frère si ce serait
stupéfiant
ce n'est pas impensable pourquoi ce qui
vous est arrivé peut très bien arriver à
une autre espèce
c'est peu probable
enfin on peut toujours le pensait
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs l'imagination des
poètes
les prêtres ont parlé des aliments font
réfléchir les animaux lafontaine a mis
sur le dos des animaux bien de nous de
nos travers et de nos idées nos pensées
c'est quelqu'un c'est dommage d'ailleurs
qu'ils soient pas là parce qu ils vous
vous aurez à affronter tout ça plus que
moi